but i loved him dearly and that man was
very very abusive towards me
um
but i still took my chances and i have a
mouthpiece on me that gets me in a lot
of trouble
but um
i
i tolerated that you know because my
self-worth was so low
all right shayna yes shayna where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
grew up in san diego and a little bit in
hawaii
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents no my parents
separated when i was nine months old
so i grew up with a mom um who i had
nine or excuse me rather seven different
dads so it was kind of rough
your mom married how many times seven
seven
i grew up in private school and part of
the country club
so i had a rather
you'd say upscale upbringing
however uh
my mom she had a nail salon
and she kind of lived a rough life with
a lot of uh her friends were porn stars
and whatnot
so my mom
she did the best she could you could say
but poor choice in men i
had a rough life
but it was covered with my grandparents
um and money and whatnot yeah but no no
terrible abuse oh no i suffered from
physical emotional and sexual abuse
growing up
yeah
made it through high school
made it through high school no i didn't
actually i ran away halfway across
country at 16 and um subsequently ended
up in continuation school
but i did get my
diploma
what did you do after that
um
after that i didn't do much i tried to
go to college i did i do have some
college completed
trade schools beauty school
real estate and some accounting
got married
um was with my husband we didn't get
married till later on but we were
together for many years raised a family
have a daughter
um
and uh was in huntington beach doing
well
um very well
got in a car accident was on some pain
medication so i was a housewife at home
raising a beautiful little girl and my
husband he had a construction company
primarily for window cleaning and um
we're doing very well in huntington
harbor
and um things fell apart after a while
our daughter was eight years old
and um
[Music]
basically um
my father who is a doctor
in chiropractor
in chiropractic rather he had found out
i tried heroin and
helped my husband get an attorney
and
put a seven-year restraining order that
i couldn't see my daughter
so i was in rehab getting off of my pain
pills
and um i had tried heroin one time
and
i just crumbled at that point um
i was in the pta and i was a room mom
for isabella and
[Music]
when
i couldn't see her anymore
and could no longer be a part of her
that's when things just crumbled i
remember i had an emotional break at
that time
i just felt my entire world
crumble
um thank you
and everything fell apart i remember
and i told my father that i was breaking
inside
and he just
told me to hold on i wasn't being strong
enough and basically called me a loser
and um
that's when i pretty much gave up i uh
i started stripping at 36 years old
i started using heroin daily
and i went straight for the needle
because i just felt that i was fighting
a losing battle i would go two visits at
the orange county um
forget child cps visiting area and i
would be strung out on cocaine
my eyes were fluttering and i was trying
to visit my daughter
broken um
but at least i was trying to show up for
the visits
but i was so broken inside
and um
lost
so i gave up on that eventually because
i could no longer function
so i left the rehab i started dating a
guy who was addicted to heroin
who would shoot me up and he was working
for vivid entertainment which is adult
industry
and came out to los angeles
and just uh blew through a bunch of
money
and was dancing and then got into porn
myself some amateur stuff that
eventually had gotten leaked
into the public i'm 45 years old now
and this is uh
me at the end of the till
the end of
this nine year run
um
graduated to fentanyl
used
subsequently after
the heroin heroin was no longer doing
its job for me
um as well as speed
and you can imagine some of the people
i've hung out with and
some of the things i've done i was doing
home invasions
um i was looking at 20 years with two
strikes two years ago in court
um and that's
and i had a boyfriend that was an
accomplice
but i took the rap and he died i think
he just got staged for liver cancer out
of the blue and he passed away three
weeks later
um in the middle of our trial
so i survived thankfully i was pregnant
um and
i had a late term abortion
i was six months pregnant
and i did have a late term abortion i
was 42 years old
with his baby
he denied the baby the entire time told
me he was going to make sure i had a
miscarriage he was going to punch the
baby and whatnot so i've been through
quite a bit
um
but it's the life that i chose
i haven't seen not one picture of my
daughter
uh let me backtrack
um
[Music]
i
did see one picture it was this year i
looked her up on facebook
and um
i was able to see one picture of her i
haven't seen her since she was eight
years old she's now 17
and um i did see one picture of her this
year and it was so
it was so beautiful
um
the family hasn't sent anything they
won't send pictures they won't send
report cards or anything like that
and i gave up sending birthday cards and
christmas cards
because i knew i wasn't doing my part as
a mom or trying to get her back after
the seven year restraining order was
lifted
i just wasn't ready or right
and i
kind of gave in to the fact that maybe
when she's an adult i can be there for
her
when i got myself right
um
coming to l.a i uh
i basically came home late i was content
to die i didn't want to kill myself
um i didn't know how and i i knew i
couldn't go to heaven if i did
so
i
would live very very dangerously
i do suffer from mental illness i don't
know if i have bipolar or just severe
depression
but um
i was doing such risky behavior that it
was amazing that i survived most days
much less most nights
can you give me an example of what
you're talking about
um well i would carry weapons on a daily
basis and when i needed money because i
i like to do things on a grand scale so
i would need money and a lot of it to do
the things i like to do
so when times would get rough i would
take cars
all the time and i would carry weapons i
would go up in people's homes if they
were home
and i would do home invasions
um a lot of them
and
[Music]
i'm not proud of that today i didn't
feel it when i would do it in 2019 i was
doing a lot of them um i didn't have
real a real conscience or really care i
was so numb
um
so that's an example
um i basically i was i had no fear
so if you had something i liked i would
let you know that i wanted that and you
can give it to me or i'm gonna take it
type of attitude and that's not pretty
or nice or ladylike at all um but that's
how i lived
um
and it was very dangerous because of the
people i would deal with
uh
you know they were just as dangerous as
i and i'm not a big
person
and i could have very much easily gotten
hurt
you know and i i have i've been slapped
by a six foot ten man a couple of times
you know and that hurts
and i was in a very abusive relationship
with a very powerful man
who used to make sixteen thousand to
twenty thousand dollars a week and that
was my boyfriend at one time for three
years and he used to
abuse the heck out of me physically
and emotionally
and i for some reason loved this man
dearly
and uh he's the one that passed away
but i loved him dearly and that man was
very very abusive towards me
but i still took my chances and i have a
mouthpiece on me that gets me in a lot
of trouble
but
i
i tolerated that you know because my
self-worth was so low
at the time
and um
the good news is i did spend some time
in jail
um over this past in 2020 i i got a six
month sit down in jail and i was looking
at a long time in prison
and um
i'm grateful that i was offered this
program again to go back into it it's a
mental health diversion
and i actually have i'm in the program
now so i'm forced to kind of sit down
and do good and
i'm doing that now
and um i'm on methadone
so i'm
grateful for that and i'm able to live
somewhat of a balanced life you could
say and i'm on is is your life less
hectic on methadone than it was on uh
absolutely fentanyl absolutely it's
managed and i'm also taking um zoloft
topomax
and um seroquel which is an
antipsychotic and
and depression medication and a mood
stabilizer which
helps me stay a little bit balanced
and keeps me functioning a little bit
more like a regular normal person
because
someone who does the drugs that i do
and for the last nine years is not a
happy person or not functioning well in
society as an a normal person quote
unquote
so there must be something chemically
going on with me maybe from ptsd from
childhood or from my boy ex-boyfriend
not an excuse
i obviously have some things to work on
and i'm in intense therapy as well
so i think those things combined helped
me function better
today and you've been living on the
streets
no i was living on the streets for nine
years
in and out of motels hotels and whatnot
and and i lived in a tent out here on
skid row you're supporting yourself wow
um by oh i was a prostitute this last
and i can't lie in the program the last
four months i've been a prostitute
um i but on a higher scale i had a web
page
and um believe it or not my customers
were police officers
yeah
i was prostituting myself to make money
so i'm not functioning that well
um
i hate to be honest like that but that's
the truth
i recently just stopped doing that yeah
i think honesty is the only way to get
past it though sure you keep it in
the closet and just
yeah um i think i will always have a
little bit of that devious side in me no
matter how good i do did you always have
that yeah even when you were younger
yeah i think i first learned when my
stepdad we were my mom was dealing with
a step down we was in a boat and he was
dealing with the cartel
and um
i would find weed packs weed or cocaine
like and he would pay me off not to tell
my mom and give me percocet at like 14
13
and weed
and like 50 bills not to tell her so i
learned at a young age um deviant
behavior
and how to like hustle
that's interesting you learned from your
dad stepfather a stepfather yeah he was
a very bad person
a very bad bad person
what emotions do you go through with all
your
you know with or without medications
um
severe
insecurity
i don't ever feel safe
i feel unprotected
i feel my mom never protected me
um
i just feel like she chose her husband's
over us children
and so i never feel safe i never feel
like my feelings are ever validated
and
i think i'm struggling with a lot of
anger
because of that
and it's really [ __ ] up because excuse
my mouth because of the way that i
approach
relationships in my adult life now
i really don't trust anybody and
it's sad because i really
run over men
and if there's been a few good ones that
have really
wanted to be close to me and i really
just
run over them
in what ways
i don't trust them i always believe that
i need to be the fun girl the girl that
they run to
not the girls i want to be the girl they
run to not the girl they want to run
away from
so i don't believe in the whole wife
thing because i think that's a big scam
because i believe that they they always
run away from the right the wife and
they run to the
side piece
so i always want to be the side piece
because that's the one that they're
honest with and that's when they have
fun with
i don't believe the wife is the one that
they want to be around
and that's a really backwards way of
thinking
in a healthy mindset
but i'm the side girl that the husbands
run to
and i know that
yeah almost your personality
makes you that way almost
my basic disposition yeah
it seems like you're not meant to be a
stay-at-home housewife
a faithful faithful wife
right and i used to think i believe in
love so much i truly do
i've just my my whole belief has a
system i believe in that so much is the
one thing i hold and cherish dearly in
this world
and um i'm just so afraid that is it
possible and true or do we have so many
like are we just meant to just be in the
moment and love who we love at that
moment is it possible to actually be
committed to one person one person or is
it possible to actually is commitment
even a reality
uh i don't even know
[Music]
who who who does
it really it's a good question we can
spend an hour on that yeah i feel like i
am so i'm the best friend to people i
can have the most fun with people
and when it comes and i'm a great fun
person
when it comes down to me getting in a
relationship i'm terrible i'm an
insecure mess
i don't trust i doubt everything
i
am awful
awful at a relationship
as much as i try not to be and try to be
that secure person that i am normally on
my own
give me a relationship and i fall to
pieces
because i just feel like i'm not worthy
they're not going to stick with me
they want the side piece not me yeah
what's your biggest fear
that
and losing there's someone that i have
in my life i'm afraid of losing him
because he's a breath of fresh air in my
life and i love him so dearly
and he's taught me how to live and enjoy
life
and he's a great person in my life and
i'm afraid of losing him
do you enjoy your your this life you've
been leading
now
i was always i was never happy until i
came to la until i started putting all
these drugs in my body until i said i'm
not gonna try to be what everybody wants
me to be
i was never happy until i came out and
just destroyed myself and rebuilt myself
up into this person i am now
who says i'm going to be happy at all
costs and i'm going to be true to myself
and let go of all these expectations of
me but like when you were
doing home invasions and all that you
were
you're happier than when you were before
yeah
yes
but i wasn't happy then that's not true
happiness right i'm happy today now
that i've gotten a grip on my brain a
little bit with my i'm happy to be on my
medication
and i'm happy to have some sort of
semblance of normality now
yeah the mental issues are a huge part
of your story
huge
and my paternal family my paternal
grandmother and whatnot suffer from
depression
my mom suffers from bipolar
so that that's a big deal to get a grip
on that and finally be able to identify
that i have some mental issues going on
and drugs are
part of your life too
absolutely i've been addicted to opiates
from a young age my aunt gave me a
vicodin at a young age where did i start
i was like 14 and i had my menstrual
cycle and it hurt so bad i like passed
out and she gave me a viking and extra
strength and from that day i was hooked
so i was always going to the er seeking
pain meds for
a pretend fall i had
that's an interesting life you've led
yeah
and i was trying to pretend that
i was okay and that nothing was going on
and when i couldn't get what i wanted
i'd go in the bathroom and drink
schnapps hundred and drink and couldn't
drink anymore i'd throw up and i'd just
keep trying to drink and i hated alcohol
but i needed a head change because i
could never function the way that normal
people did
i just couldn't do what normal people
did i felt
i i didn't like it
i just didn't like life the way that on
life's terms
what do you find do you find it's too
boring yeah
yes getting up and taking a shower and
getting ready for work that to me is
just like i cannot just live like that
torture
but now i'm a little bit medicated for
10 months now i've been on medication i
feel like that's what i do now and i
enjoy it it's regular
so i know i needed to balance my
and plus with the drugs i was using take
away all your dopamine and all your
serotonin right
so no wonder i wasn't happy doing normal
things like that
and i was depressed so i didn't have a
lot of serotonin before so i'm trying to
understand
maybe what was going on
but happy people don't use the drugs i
was using
as often as you i was using them
so
[Music]
but yeah i guess i'm just one of those
ones that are struggle with
a bad seed maybe
you know yes yeah if you're doing all
these talks with all these different
people
it seems like some of us are just
genetically predisposed to
live
a chaotic life
yes and that's exactly what because i do
everything
they're incapable of walking a straight
line
totally incapable of it
and capable
and always unhappy and never fit in and
never feel comfortable
and always feel insecure and out of
place
and never never
just always feel like something's wrong
with them and then you're judged all the
time by your families
yeah and you don't understand why and
you just feel like nobody understands
you
and i feel like i almost feel like the
next guy who maybe
uh going through a sex change or
something like that you you identify
with them even though i look the way i
do i look perfectly like a normal girl
that everything would be okay with
but
i can identify with the not fitting in
or feeling like something's wrong just
because of the emotions i go through
with my own
things i struggle with
i can identify with people that truly
just don't feel like they fit in regular
society
which is a strange
thing and it's hard to explain yeah and
there's not an easy fix for it either
even the medications you're taking are
somewhat of an experiment yeah
let's see if this works let's see if
that works right
right and it's hard to put your finger
on what don't how do you not fit in then
you're taking this these three drugs
with these this new drug and just
encountering
right and there's side effects to all of
it you know weight gain i'm 20 pounds
heavier than i like to be
um this that another nice struggle with
anorexia you know after i had my
daughter i went down to 98 pounds
thinking people would take me seriously
if i was thin that's crazy
normal people don't think that way
you know
and my mom struggles because she doesn't
like to hear me talk like that
you know she doesn't want to hear that i
think that i'm like
a little different or off she doesn't
want to hear that i'll ask a stupid
question you're the black sheep of your
family
and how's your relationship with
your family well my mom's a black sheep
too my mom's a little wild wow
right my relationship with my family is
um
different i'm the only one that really
goes to jail and you know all that my
family's like middle america republican
like everyone else goes to church you go
to jail
right and i stay there i don't just go
for a night i go and i stay for like two
to six months
you know lucky to get out type thing
so it's contentious you could say my dad
last or his last words to me i was a
loser and that that was it for me that
was nine years ago
um
he's always been kind of a prick he
likes to make fun of my mom and talk
[ __ ] about my mom but and and say what a
bad person she is or what not or how
crazy she is
but it dawned on me how could he judge
her if he thinks that way about her why
did he leave me in her care and not
really be a part of my life then
if that's how he really feels
you know and then his wife was
a piece of [ __ ] i'd go up there and my
dad was in medical school and i'd be in
hawaii with her and she would like
do terrible things to try to like
torment me like terrible things
she would like kill my cabbage patch
dolls like put ketchup on them and like
hang them from a rope in the hallway
like that's terrible to do to a
seven-year-old little girl
like she would torment me
and like make me watch horror movies
that used to scare me to death like
that's terrible to do to a child
you know and i didn't even tell my
father about that till i was in my 20
late 20s
you know like you just don't you don't
terrorize a child like that
especially one who doesn't want to be
there
you know
so i had a lot of [ __ ] up things
happen to me
that i could never tell anybody about so
i have a lot of emotions that i really
never dealt with that come out now in
adulthood
that i don't understand how to deal with
and it's kind of too late to even deal
with them but a lot of trust issues and
a lot of fear i still carry with me
you know and people don't understand
that now and most my mom's the type of
person she doesn't want to deal with it
it's too much it hurts her it makes her
feel uncomfortable so she would rather
just not hear about it
um you know
so yeah it's this life hasn't been easy
for me
but i finally came to a point where i
was like forget it i don't want to live
in those fear moments anymore i don't
want to live feeling insecure anymore so
i just
i numbed myself so much with drugs and
figured i was going to just do it my way
for a while
what's been your darkest moment
you seem to be a little better right now
yeah yeah a lot better my darkest moment
was when i
stayed living in those moments
my darkest moments would be when i
stayed living not even the drugs and not
even hell
being on the drugs my darkest moments
were
in staying living in those moments um
trying to
be what i be happy in those moments
just trying to be something i'm not
um i would say my darkest moments were
staying in orange county and
trying to make everybody else happy and
trying to go to cps and see my daughter
and
living at my trying to stay with my mom
temporarily
and she telling me to get a job and my
step-sister was living there she told me
to get a job so and us to get jobs to
pay rent so you know what i did i
grabbed her and i pimped her out for the
day
got her a date
pimped her out for the day and then made
her go with me to the strip club and
start a stripper job that night
and that was my mom's husband's daughter
she was in her 20s i was in my 30s
and i said we got job pubs
and we brought home a lot of money we
got jobs they were not too thrilled
about that but i was like
that was just my attitude that was
probably a dark moment and i also
crashed their house i had a big
navigator at the time and i came in and
they they were living in a big
double-sized motorhome that they love
they have money they don't have to live
there but they love it
i crashed down their house like
literally the whole porch park crashed
down
when i came home that night
so that was probably a dark moment
because i was trying to make them happy
at the same time kind of saying [ __ ] you
in a way and brought her along
so
yeah that was a dark moment
what's been the the purest form of love
you've experienced in your life
outside of with my little girl
um
the purest form of love is uh that i
have somebody in my life that i truly
truly love dearly
that
i just
love this person
unconditionally
and it was the first time i ever really
truly felt like real love
um
i can't describe a particular moment
it's just a feeling that i have and then
i know it's like really cool
it's beautiful
and um
uh i don't know how to describe it but
it's it's really really beautiful
and
it's a feeling this person gives me a
lot
and
uh
i want this person to be happy no matter
what
whatever the choices are that makes this
person happy like i support 100 you know
that's great
so it's um just their their aura is of
love me to them is of love you know what
i mean like
it's hard to it's hard to just explain
like i don't have words
it's beyond me
yeah maybe maybe that would be what what
saves you
right
yeah
and they came to me recently with some
really cool things
that they had said to me and um
it was pretty pretty like amazing and i
almost couldn't accept it because i was
like
you know you love me like that you know
i was really shocked and um you know
i was beautiful
really beautiful and i'm having a hard
time accepting it you know i'm just i'm
kind of chasing him away and pushing him
away accepting that kind of stuff yeah
big challenge yeah
yeah what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your
crazy life
life is short
life is beautiful
but the most important lesson i've
learned is that
the law of attraction is real
um what you put your thoughts into and
your energy into
is what you attract manifestation is
real
and um what we put our energies into
whether it be negative or positive we
get
so i strongly encourage myself on a
daily basis to thank god and to
really focus on positivity because i'm
going to get it back
whatever i put my energy into it's going
to come back to me
yeah shayna thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you
you